la pandémie du coronavirus pourrait-elle
être la cause du report des jeux
olympiques de tokyo au japon
le doute s'accroît sur la tenue du plus
grand événement sportif de 2020 un
sondage publié lundi par l' agence de
presse kyodo révèle que 69 9% de la
population ne croit pas que tokyo pourra
accueillir les jo du moins aux dates
prévues
la gouverneur de switch yuriko koike
affirme elle qu'il est impossible
d'annuler les jeux olympiques ce que je
dois dire en tant que responsable d'une
ville haute
c'est qu'il est impossible d'annuler les
jeux olympiques ou de les organiser sans
spectateurs comme je l' ai déjà dit en
tant que ville hôte ce qui nous importe
le plus c'est de savoir comment
organiser les jo en respectant des
normes sanitaires et sécuritaires élevé
et pour ce faire il faut vaincre le
nouveau coronavirus c'est la principale
condition
le comité international qui compte pour
sa part de jouer la montre en raison de
la crise sanitaire et des mesures
restrictives décrétée par des
gouvernements du monde entier
le cio a débuté ce mardi des
consultations pour évoquer le maintien
des jeux de tokyo après une réunion avec
les fédérations internationales comités
nationaux et autres représentants des
athlètes
l'institution souhaite que la
compétition se déroule bel et bien aux
dates prévues à savoir du 24 juillet au
9 août prochain
[Musique]
nous avons également été constructif
dans la mesure où tout cela a été
accompli avec tokyo en ligne de mire
tout le monde s'est rendu compte que
nous avions plus de quatre mois devant
nous
une décision soutenue par martin
fourcade le président de la commission
des athlètes de paris 2024 justifie la
temporisation du cio laissons-nous le
temps de voir comment la situation
évolue on n'est pas à deux semaines ou
un mois après pour annuler aujourd'hui
ça ne sert à rien de spéculer on est
encore loin des jeux un choix qui va à
l'encontre de la stratégie des autres
instances mondiales du sport
en effet depuis plusieurs jours de
nombreuses fédérations décide
successivement du report de leur
événement comme l'euro de football
repoussé à l'été 2000 21e tournoi de
tennis de roland garros où l'épreuve
cycliste du paris roubaix sont également
repoussé à des dates ultérieures de ce
contexte le maintien des jeux olympiques
et donc de plus en plus contesté alors
que tous les sports cessent leur
activité et que les reports des grands
événements se multiplient le cio évoque
le maintien possible djo je suis atterré
par tant d'inconséquence il ya des pays
moins touché que d'autres certains
peuvent s'entraîner normalement pendant
que nous on ne peut même pas accéder à
notre terrain d'entraînement il faut
reporter les jo à la fin de l'année 2020
si les préparatifs pour ces jeux
olympiques d'été semble à avancer comme
si de rien n'était il faudra attendre
plusieurs semaines pour savoir si la
compétition pourra se dérouler cet été
mais une chose est sûre santé et
sécurité devront être les premières
priorités
[Musique]